[Music]
seventy-five years ago this week Europe
ended its darkest chapter in history
with the liberation of the Nazi
concentration camp of Auschwitz Birkenau
which saw the systemic murder of six
million Jews and many other minorities
under Hitler I was fortunate enough to
interview Holocaust survivor manfred
goldberg and he issued to me a warning
about resurgent anti-semitism in modern
times and would be foolhardy if we did
not heed it anti-semitism is the one
ring of racism to unite all extremes
far-left far-right and Islamist
extremists all hate each other but the
one thing they agree on is their hatred
for Jews the modern manifestation of
this ancient hatred defeated as it was
knows it cannot attack out in the open
and so shrouds itself in euphemisms but
Britain is the nation that stood strong
against Jew hate during our darkest hour
now just as then we shall not be fooled
if never again is to mean anything at
all it is to call out this evil before
we all sleep walk towards it again so
let me be clear
cloaking your anti-semitism in the name
of anti-zionism will no longer cut it
anti-zionism
is anti-semitism II imagine I'm reminded
that you and I have spoken of course at
events for CST which is the organisation
are just before I move for not just one
of the most fascinating aspects that
came out of some of the most powerful
documentaries I've seen that we
witnessed was the narrative that's
emerging now that any of the material
that was photographed by the Nazis
should we actually be showing that now
because that is through their lens that
is how they wanted to see Jewish people
portrayed as almost Department almost
like vermin being rounded into ghettos
with the children come here and by
continuing to play that are we actually
allowing that it's not yeah we're
actually allowing the Nazi prospect now
post liberation where you see the bodies
being treated effectively with piles of
rubbish again in some instances those
could be people's grandparents so
they're seeing that the face is
contorted and twisted and the numbers
there are so many aspects but to your
central point
I don't need to remind you because I
know you're close to it it was just
around christmas or hanukkah time that
the parts of North London were had some
graffiti we've seen terrible attacks in
the United States recently and in France
you are apps
regrettably majid and you are absolutely
and wholly right this is something that
needs to be combatted and I have to
point to we touched on this briefly the
general election you sort of touched on
it in an earlier conversation sadly
there are issues within the Labour Party
which they are seeking to address but if
in any way that is seen to legitimize
this vile sense of racism which I think
through some it might that is something
that needs to be addressed very very
urgently I I think you're all wrong in
this sense because I have watched a few
documentaries this week and and the
horror of what you say I think we need
to be reminded of that so that people
know what that equals because young
people today a lot them don't have any
idea about the Holocaust of what
happened there but but I still this
deeply embedded hostility towards Jews
as a race and we see it and it's on the
March you're saying let's not happen
again it's happening it's happening in
France seventy-four percent rise in
anti-semitic attacks in France in
Germany more than a sixty percent rise
in this country we see that the Labour
Party is is infused with anti-semitism
and we talk about and what worries me in
this country is we talked about it we
say how terrible it is we say how awful
it isn't it mustn't be allowed to happen
and yet we tolerate it and and in
tolerating it we allow it to flourish
I've got a statistic for the perception
of anti sound anti-semitism we just see
the Labour Party we've mentioned two or
three times so let me just then I'll
come straight to the Labour Party says
for we are taking decisive and robust
action to root out the small minority in
our party who have engaged in
anti-semitism and we are raising
awareness about anti-semitic stereotypes
and conspiracy theories to enable more
people to challenge and call them out
yes in perception of anti-semitism
across the EU in night 2018 eighty-nine
percent thought that anti-semitism had
increased in the last five years I mean
I think you moved us on to a slightly
different area when you said that
anti-semitism and anti-zionism should be
exactly synonymous I think that there
are difficulties with that when you've
seen the Trump peace plan which
completely excludes
Palestinians from Jerusalem you can
understand why I stand crutches or you
work you can understand why there is
there still has to be a conversation
about the role of Israel so but let's it
can we segregate that friend just to
clarify because yeah clarify Zionism and
I think this is where there's a common
misunderstanding especially in British
political parlance it's important to
clarify that when people especially Jews
when they use the word Zionism they
simply mean the Jewish rights my
homeland that's very different to for
example the detailed conversations as to
whether East Jerusalem it should be a
capital of Palestine and so it
criticized Netanyahu sorry criticized
netting young criticized policies of the
Israeli government but like Britain and
America I believe wrongfully invaded
Iraq that doesn't mean I now suddenly
say America doesn't have the right to
exist Britain doesn't have the right to
exist
Zionism is simply that is the right for
the Jewish people to have a homeland and
unfortunately the conflation of critic
critic of the to actually helps
anti-semitism because because most of
the water yeah one thing that always
gets a problem in this debate is on this
in this conversation is the idea that
the moment you mentioned what happened
in that in the nineteen thirties and
fourties you're saying that this person
or this movement is exactly the same and
and therefore and therefore it everyone
anytime you mention that you get accused
of Godwin's law you get accused of
exaggerating we the whole point of
history is to learn lessons from history
not because there's often the phrase
Hitler Hitler doesn't in hich history
doesn't repeat it echoes yeah I just
wanted to let's hear from an ultimate
survivor on a salt who's speaking at
events from Auschwitz itself I get very
very nervous every time I come here
that's not that it reminds me because I
never forget what happened here but I
come here because I'm going to show
other people what happened to explain to
them what what happened here I am
worried that it eventually people forget
about it I hope not but
we tried to keep it going people like
the Holocaust survivors Holocaust
education trust they keep it going I
hope they'll keep it going for many many
years now why that's relevant to Zionism
and not Israeli government policies is
because of course that's why Jews needed
a homeland they have been hounded and
discriminated against in almost every
single European country and across the
world and so Zionism wants to provide a
safe space for Jews where they wouldn't
be but don't you think what scares me is
things are creeping back into society
you know we're seeing the re-emergence
of anti-semitic tropes rhe Jews and
money the you they use fundamental
rights agency says that and that
anti-semitic hate speech and harassment
is now becoming the new norm in
countries all over you around in
American understand and and it scares me
that it's creeping and you know we
pretend that it can't happen again but
you know on the very day of liberation
day on Tuesday of outrage and we saw
those petula people flying in from
around the world and and heads of state
flying in to be with them people in East
London what drama word or being
anti-semitic slogans on buildings and
that's in London so it's happening it's
too late it is creeping and that's what
happened in Nazi Germany and we mustn't
pretend and that's why this lady said
Nick you know we're frightened people
will forget that's why I think the
documented film is really important so
that people don't feel like things be
aware that there is a sense that we're
watching the way the Nazis wanted to
portray the Jewish people which was a
subclass living in ghettos like that so
we just have to be aware of that as long
as it's coupled with what you see when
they liberated Belsen when they
liberated out that that is that because
it is some of the most shocking there's
not the most shocking innocence in my
view and this is just a personal
suggestion I think particular in terms
of dealing with anti-semitism and
political parties it would be very good
if the heads of various two of pretty
much every major Jewish organization
formed a committee to police and moretz
their political parties so that well
it's a Security Trust the Jewish
community has come up with a proposal
which is to equate all anti-semitism
with any sort of racism so let's just
hear from the chief executive of
Jewish Leadership Council Simon Johnson
the issue I feel is that over the last
few years anti-jewish racism has stopped
being socially unacceptable it sort of
had slightly bigger coverage people who
have been anti-semitic have felt
emboldened perhaps because of the
political climate and I think what we
need to see is for it to become socially
unacceptable
again I think over the last few weeks
and months when people have seen the
quite higher levels of anti-jewish
racism around in political discourse I
think people have been shocked and I
think we're returning to a time where
quite rightly anti-jewish racism is just
as unacceptable as racism against any
other part of society as this week
finishes I think it's really important
that the memory of the Holocaust does
not fade from memory into history you're
watching the pledge coming up
Carol that match last night can you
believe the VAR decision shut up so
after this
[Music]